welcome everyone um to a
special edition of the ohsu
informatics research conference we um
normally meet on thursdays but at the
end of the term we have a number of
students
defending theses proposals etc um
and so that's what we're doing today we
are
um hearing from samantha lawson who's a
master of science student
in the bioinformatics and computational
biomedicine major
samantha will be defending
her thesis and um
as most of you know the process for that
is that she presents
her work and then there are public
questions
then the public is dismissed leaving
behind her committee
who may ask her further questions and
then she is dismissed and the committee
decides whether or not the
defense is successful um and of course
that's required to
obtain the master of science degree in
our program um
just a quick uh bio about samantha she
received her bachelor of science in
biochemistry in spanish
from whitworth university in spokane
she's
worked in a number of labs over the
years
most recently serving as a research
assistant
at the knight cancer institute for three
and a half years
she's currently the lab manager for dr
george thomas in the night
prostate program and her research
interests include exploring
genomic analysis tools to aid in the
molecular
biology environment so i will
um turn the floor over to samantha
thank you very much okay let's
do this
okay um thank you everyone for
joining me today and thank you dr hirsch
for introduction
i'm just gonna kind of dive right in so
today i'm gonna start with um the topic
uh relevant vocab so that we all have
a baseline for uh knowledge base for the
rest of the presentation
uh move into our motivation spend quite
a bit of time on background
information um go through the research
question
and subsequent hypotheses and then
outline the specific aims at that point
we're going to turn into what i've done
since the proposal
so i proposed back in june and since
then
i'll talk about the methodology results
discussion
potential future work and then questions
at the end
so my final working title for this
thesis
is predictive modeling of pharaptosis
susceptibility using
iron dependent pathways in renal cell
carcinoma
i want to break this down into four key
pieces so that we all
kind of understand where we're going
with the rest of the presentation
so predictive modeling i emphasize this
because i wanted to create a
numerical tool that takes in one
input measurement of a basal cell
characterization um and then it gives
that outcome
variable of ferrotosis susceptibility
ferrotosis susceptibility
meaning how much inducing agent or how
much treatment
is needed to induce a cell type into
theraptosis which is this newly
discovered type of cell death that i'll
discuss
later on and then i
emphasize iron dependent pathways so
this new mechanism
has two separate arms the lipid
peroxidation side and the iron
accumulation
side the lip approximation arm of this
i feel has been focused on more recently
and so i hope to kind of illuminate more
of that iron accumulation
side of this mechanism i also believe
that the there's an interesting kind of
research in metallomix within the cancer
research field
that's kind of a cool new topic
so i wanted to look into that and then
finally renal cell carcinoma is the
setting that i
researched this in so i built my model
on those cell lines from different
subtypes within kidney cancer
so the motivation for this project one
is to provide another kind of mechanism
to target if treatment options
of other mechanisms have proven
ineffective
and that tumor or site is resistant
to those treatment options so having
this newer type of cell death creates a
new target to look at
and so by adding more characterization
to the knowledge base that's currently
built on ferro ptosis you're kind of
aiding that advancement
in this mechanism next
i wanted to create an accessible
assay-based method
to model the pharaptosis
prediction in these cell lines and i
want to highlight accessible here
the the goal was to create something
that the broader research community
could use without too much
time or cost expense and so i was hoping
to make a simplistic way
for other researchers within the
spheriptosis field
to access and predict
what will occur in their settings
fourth incorporate models into
biological research
with more frequency so as i said earlier
kind of create this simpler
illustration of what is going on within
these cells
and then finally give insight into how
these different settings will behave in
the hopes of transitioning into more
heterogeneous contexts
here we're starting in cell lines but
the idea would be to advance this into
something more complex such as an
organoid or xenograft or ideally
into the humor human tumor tissue
um a side note about this ferrotosis
can be used in multiple different ways
since we are in the cancer context
realm we the goal is to induce
reptosis to kill those cancer cells
however
in neurodegenerative diseases the goal
there would
be to inhibit those cells from going
into
ptosis to kind of conserve that
brain cell function and this is seen in
parkinson's alzheimer's and it's even
seen that with
ferrotosis inhibiting treatments
they're able to lessen the damage from
different
stroke conditions such as ischemic and
hemorrhagic
okay moving on to background so as i
said earlier
this is a fairly new type of cell death
that was just named in 2012 by the
stockwell laboratory in columbia
university
in new york city um and those were that
laboratory was kind of the key
one of the key players in the early days
of theraptosis so many of these early
publications came out of that lab
they showed that when you add iron
into a a rastan treated
arrest in being a pharaptosis-inducing
agent which i'll talk about more
when you add iron into that setting the
cell death
accelerates significantly
and then two years later it uh this
mechanism was shown to be regulated by
glutathione peroxidase iv glutathione
peroxidase iv
is the main kind of
enzyme in this mechanism and i'll talk
quite a bit more about it
later on a year later lipid metabolism
was shown to be involved in the
mechanism
i wanted to highlight this mostly
because as i stated earlier
that this process is divided into those
two parts iron accumulation and lipid
peroxidation
and just five years ago was lip was that
second arm identified and so we can see
the increase
in um how quickly this
research is being advanced and then two
years later
pes or phosphatidyl ethanol amines were
showed
to be oxidized during this process again
another example of how this is being
narrowed down as pes are a species
within that lipid metabolome
um moving
on to the actual process now i know
there's a lot going on in this slide and
so i'm just going to highlight a few
things panel a is what
i'm going to focus on so we all have
kind of some background knowledge of
what's going on within this process
however panel b is this iron metabolism
side here i just want to illustrate the
complexity of what goes on
in this arm of the pathway
so to begin we're going to start with
our fe2 plus over here
or our iron pool this undergoes a fenton
react
fenton reaction which the iron combines
with
hydrogen peroxide and creates toxic free
radicals within the cell
now over here we have our gpx4 regulator
this is able to
take glutathione react with these lipid
peroxides
so that our cell does not go into
ferrotosis
if the gpx4 is not
functioning that those lipid peroxides
accumulate with
in the cell and kill the cell
so another point um another targetable
area
is the cysteine glutamate antiporter
this
brings cysteine within the cell
which is then converted to glutathione
which tpx4
then uses in that interaction i just
mentioned
where it is able to use that lipid
peroxide glutathione
and remove it from the cell um
two notes here this is a regulated type
of cell death it is not accidental
and it can be distinguished between the
other types of cell death such as
apoptosis necroptosis
etc it
can be that is done by using ferrostatin
here
which if added to a pharyptotic cell
will rescue
the cell if added to any of the of the
other
um like apoptotic cell
it will not rescue the cell and it'll
undergo that cell death
pathway so these again
the cysteine glutamate antiporter and
gpx4
are targetable areas for
um their inducing ferroptosis
another note is over here this kind of
section is
um the iron chelator so a dfo is an iron
chelator that mops up
that excess iron within the cell and
will
inhibit the cell from undergoing
ferroptosis
okay so we have our targetable areas
i want to talk about the inducing agents
now
a small molecule assessment was done to
determine which compounds
were able to induce cells into ptosis
multiple
compounds were found and for my purposes
i want to focus
on arastin and rsl3 arastin
is a class 1 ferroptosis-inducing agent
meaning that it inhibits that cysteine
glutamate anti-porter
cysteine cannot come into the cell
cannot go through that
interaction and then combine
use glutathione to combine with lipid
peroxides
rsl3 is a class 2 for ptosis and
disinfectant
this inhibits the gpx4
system to induce the cell into very
ptosis
so we have multiple targets and with
that we're able to
understand or kind of manipulate the
mechanism at two different parts
there are other inducing agents that
have been shown to be successful
however they do also target those same
areas
okay moving on to drug sensitivity so
for our outcome variable of this model
is drug sensitivity which will uh
tell us how susceptible our cells are to
ferrotosis
so because it's our outcome variable i
wanted to ensure that it's the most
consistent and accurate metric
for this model
so i after some research
into drug sensitivity metrics i
there it was determined that i see 50 or
the normal or
traditional type of metric for drug
sensitivity
is correlated with seeding number
meaning that the experiment conditions
heavily influence
this metric ic50 is the maximal or sorry
the
inhibitory concentrate at 50 meaning
that
um with our control cells it's the dose
at which our cell count
reaches 50 compared to our control cells
so
growth rate gr 50 which
takes into account that seating number
or those experimental conditions
which looks at um what the
the number of cells that were seeded our
control
cell count what rate of growth that was
and then the dose
at which that rate of growth is 50
so because this is shown to be more
consistent and it's not influenced by
those seating numbers or experimental
changes
that is what i decided to use as our
outcome variable for this model
and then moving on to
renal cell carcinoma so renal cell
carcinoma is one of the top 10 most
lethal cancers in the u.s
and is most sensitive to ferro ptosis
over here we show how different
cancers react to a class
one inducing ferrotosis inducing agent
and here we can see that renal cancer
is affected the most
but we also can see that there's a wide
range of sensitivity across
these settings and so over
in the more shallower graphs you can see
that
lesson sensitivity
so the biology behind renal cell
carcinoma and why that is more sensitive
to ferrotosis has been shown recently
and it has to do with the majority of
renal cell carcinoma is made up of
a clear cell subtype about 70 percent
and that undergoes a mutation quite
frequently
within the vhl or von hippel lindau
uh tumor suppressor which then is
inactivate
down the path leads to an activation of
this hypoxia inducible factor pathway
which leads to an increase in
angiogenesis
and those those hallmarks of cancer
and another a um you know the
output of this is an increase in the
polyunsaturated fatty acids of the cell
it creates an enriched state of those
lipids that i mentioned
earlier the higher accumulation of these
lipids at the basal state before any
treatment is introduced
leads to a higher sensitivity to
ferrotosis
so that made um kind of led to the
conclusion that those pufas or those
polyunsaturated fatty acids
are the rate limiting agent in this
mechanism
okay i'm going to explain some assays
that helped inform the model
so here we're looking at
immunofluorescence
or sorry just fluorescence images of
label iron pool
within the within the cell at different
localizations
so as i said that iron accumulation
side of this mechanism is what i'm
focusing on and so
this is one of the features that i
wanted to look at for the model
this is somewhat new chemistry it's only
been the publications that have used
this assay have only been around for
or published within the last five to six
years
um and there's multiple localizations as
you can see across the top here
these are all different assays so
um to choose what would be most accurate
and consistent for my model
i took into account that here you're
looking at control
cells within the mitochondria so we're
going to focus
on this area here and we see that our
iron signal is low
and it's increased with the ferrotosis
inducing agent
right that's what we would expect to see
however when you induce ferrotosis and
you add on that iron chelator that i
mentioned earlier
you should see a decrease in iron as
that
iron chelator is mopping up that excess
iron
um and you don't see that here so
i stayed away from this assay and
similar here you see the same trend but
it's not
as significant as in the
endoplasmic reticulum and golgi
localization
of the label iron pool within the cell
um that's a and so this is all
quantified in this bar chart over here
you can see that the trend is most
significant
in this localization and the authors of
this paper
did this at a time point which showed at
other times this assay here
was the most consistent so
after taking into this into account and
looking at
manufacturers recommendations i chose
that pharaoh knox one which is this
assay here
sorry is the most consistent and
accurate for measuring that
label iron pool however other assays
have their specializations
so lyso rhonox measures this
localization
and then there's ferrofar red which is
also measures the er but is used for
more flow cytometry purposes
okay bringing in this into a little more
um
database or yeah so fardb
was published in early this year march
of this year
it's a database specific to those
markers characterizations
diseases and agents for fear
ptosis and it's um
they also have other functionalities to
visualize the networks within this
mechanism
and it is what i used to pull among
other things to pull features for my
model
um i think it's a kind of a great
environment for pharaptosis researchers
to
contribute and they're able to add to
this
knowledge base um this was done by a
group
out of guangzhou chengdu china and
it still is growing very rapidly um
i also believe that with added
functionality such as
a model that is created for
the research community to use um would
be
a good opportunity to kind of contribute
and bring all of the researchers
together to help um
kind of advance that field there
so modeling options so there have been
a lot of models created for other types
of cell death apoptosis necroptosis etc
for ptosis not so much
this was one that was published
this year it is a more
simulation based model takes in quite a
few different features
and it's granular it's a 0 1 2
bin and there are 8 intermediates along
the way
and it it shows what
should occur within the cell it's not
yes it's predictive in the fact that
they were able to
test this on ovarian stem cell line
and confirm that this in fact did occur
and so this has helped inform the model
that i
wanted to create however it was a much
different motivation
again i wanted to i'm create or i
created something that
is more um i would i'd like to say
somewhat
accessible so that we have one feature
going out in and we're able to predict
how
the cell will react
okay so our research question
can iron-dependent probes including
protein abundance
and assay measurements predict
pharaptosis
sensitivity in a solid tumor cell line
um and if that is possible can this be
validated
and generalized across contexts to other
cancer
types and again this is looking at those
innate
factors within the cell we're we're
using those
basal measurements
um our hypothesis is yes these
markers can be utilized as direct
predictors for susceptibility
and once that is quantified they can be
expanded to other contexts
so our specific aims identify
the predictors that inform
ptosis cell fate um and so again these
were
pulled from fair db and
other previous publications and i want
to note that i'm purposefully leaving
out the iron dependent
probe specification here because i want
to pull
all features that could be a predictor
in our model
in case we determine that no
iron-dependent probes are unable
to predict pharaptosis successfully i
would still like to
create a model that is based off other
types of probes such as oxidative stress
and the lipid peroxidation that we
chatted about and then
two develop a mathematical model to
predict
hyptosis susceptibility and again
emphasis on this mathematical prediction
so that we're
we're not using a granular system we're
trying to create a more
um fine-tuned prediction method
and then determine the extent at which
this model can be generalized
kind of see if we can um
can apply it to a different context and
if we can't apply it where are those
limitations
so new stuff the methodology that in the
last six months i've
put together so i started with viability
assays using cell tighter blue
this was done over 72 hours and this
again is our outcome variable
this shows how sensitive each cell line
is to our pharaptosis-inducing agents
erastin or rsl3
as i said earlier priority was given to
iron-dependent assays
however i did pull in anti melon
dialdehyde
as an antibody to measure ferrotos um
to measure that oxidative stress
of the cell at the basal level to see if
that can inform our model this was
a 48 hour pro incubation
and was done via iaf
protein abundance was quantified using
western blots
um and this was uh
the specific markers i were looking at
was hmox or
heme oxygenase dmt-1 a divalent metal
transporter or fth
ferritin heavy chain so again these are
iron dependent
probes that we were looking at and
lastly iron assays ferron ox1
and ferrofar red that i spoke about
earlier
quantification was done using image j
as it's the most um accessible
popular open source tool that's used for
quantification in these f or
settings and then data organization and
visualization was done in r
there were quite a few packages that i'm
very grateful for that were published in
the last couple
months actually that helped with
visualizing
those drug sensitivity metrics
and some of our model specifications
so classic model
building steps here however we're going
to spend most of our time on
feature selection so
earlier i pointed out the if
quantification and the western block
quantification
our anti-mda signal was great it was
consistent
good quality data i did exploratory data
analysis on all of our features all of
our the possible features
and then looked at correlation analysis
as well so
anti-mda hold up to the standards there
however it's not an iron dependent probe
and the biology but
behind why that marker at a basal level
would induce pharaptosis
is a bit more unclear at this point in
time
quantification of western blots was
performed
using image studio which is one of the
most popular
quantification methods and after eda
and correlation actually we didn't get
to correlation analysis after eda
showed that there was no consistency
between assays there um
it was not uh it did not hold up to
standards and after a bit of research
this has been shown
in multiple publications there is one in
2018 that
um compared all of these different
quantification techniques of western
blots and showed
that they are misleading in nature due
to a
discrepancy between amount of protein
being loaded
but that's a topic for another day
um and so
after all of that after discovering
which
features were one consistent good
quality and then looking at correlation
analyses with our outcome variable
i decided to stick with our label iron
pool measurement that i discussed
earlier um and then we moved on to model
selection with one feature and a good
correlation
simple linear regression um and then it
was tested and validated on
other cell lines which i will talk about
shortly
okay so here are our outcome
variables it's a bit confusing but i'll
walk through
so each line here is a different
cell line this is measuring that growth
rate metric that i was discussing
um so we can see between here that
the lines aren't identical between
treatments but they are similar and so
we know that we are hitting different
targets within that pathway
so from these curves we are able to
calculate
that fifth that dose at which 50 percent
of the growth rate growth rate occurs
and so from there we were able to
correlate
with our chosen feature selection
here is that first iron measurement that
i was talking about these are ferro nox
one assay measurements or images
so ferronox one um
attaches to that mitochondrial label
iron pool and we can see this signal
here so with our tk10 which is the most
resistant
cell type we see a very limited
iron signal move over to achn which is a
more sensitive
cell type and we see an increase in iron
signal
and then finally on our right here we
see
this achn cell line with the gpx
4g knocked out meaning that this
requires no treatment
to be induced into pharah ptosis so i
used this
cell line this genetically modified cell
line
as a extreme and a control
um all of our cell line iron signals
measured below this
and i will show you where that would lie
in our
correlation analyses
so see a direct correlation between the
iron signal and drug sensitivity
if we require more rsl3 dosage
we have a lower iron signal
so if we need a higher dose of rsl3
to be pushed into ferrotosis our iron
signal will be at its lowest
if we need a small amount if we're very
sensitive to rsl3
then we will have a high iron signal if
we mapped
that knockout cell line onto this
plot it would be way over here we have
it needs zero to be induced into the
ptosis and it has extremely high
iron signal the same with erastin
and then because i
was able to use only one feature making
the model more accessible i wanted to
ensure that it was accurate
and stood up to a secondary assay so i
performed
ferrofar red which also measures that
mitochondrial localization
and here is that iron signal for the
resistance cell type
for the sensitive cell type and then
again the
extreme control of our gpx4 knockout
cell line
so specifications for this linear
regression
we're able to account for more variance
in our rsl3
model then in our arrested model it's
still
um it's and i'd like to
kind of point out why this is so
we have to take into account the dosing
range for each inducing agent
because if that range is greater we're
going to see more variability within our
data
rsl3 dosing range is between 5 nanomolar
and 100 nanomolar to see those cells be
induced into cell death
arrastin is around 50 nanomolar to 5000
nanomolar
and so we'll see a variation within that
within the data
showing that the the cells react
um more i don't know more
deep uh the cells react in a more
predictable way when the dosing range is
smaller our p values
show this is significant and so we're
happy with
it
so on to the last specific aims
i chose to try to generalize this
to v160 cell line which is a prostate
cancer cell life
and took the cell viability
and the ferrunox one iron signal and
tried to apply
this model to a separate context
here we see very shallow curves
for our inducing agent and we also see
a very low iron signal so this fits with
our trend
meaning this cell line is very resilient
ptosis
and it has a minimal iron signal to
ferro nox
so try to apply our model however
our cell viability here
has a gr50 of infinity and so we are
unable
to accurately apply this
it's um i believe it's it's a good
example of it fitting our trend however
it also illustrates the boundaries
that this model has if we build it on
the most sensitive cell type and cancer
context
and try to apply one of the least
sensitive
um cell lines or
cancer contexts it's going to not
it's going to show these boundaries and
so narrowing that gap
between the most sensitive and the most
resistant
could be helpful in expanding this model
okay discussion so
one we were able to find significant and
reliable features
so again that iron the iron measurement
within
the cell
showed that it could be consistent
across it was quality data
we have that single feature input which
makes it
um accessible to other researchers and
it's one of the shortest protocols
i looked at for the features to consider
um 2a linear regression
model was created to predict
how the cells would undergo pharaptosis
with a certain amount of inducing agent
and then the model proved to be not
generalizable
generalizable but um
with more work as um to build to
generalize it to
more sensitive cell types would be
useful in this
setting
so some future work again
continue with those iron measurements as
they proved effective
and consistent um and then also look at
that
and anti-mda uh feature that i talked
about again
good data but the biology behind it
needs to be explored more to make it
useful in this context
as this is a somewhat newer type of cell
death
the pathways are still being determined
and
characterizations are still being made
so we may
find other targetable areas or other
inducing agents as this work is being
done
um as i said earlier use a wider range
of cancer context so that
you're able to kind of build this model
gradually up instead of kind of jumping
from point a to point b
um and then share in a collaborative
space
such as fair db create functionality in
these
kind of contributive resource
hubs so that other researchers can also
add
and find helpfulness
in those computational tools
so i believe that is
it are there any questions
great thank you for your talk and
um we will open the floor to questions
um uh people can either unmute and ask
or they can type into the chat box
okay well um i'm sure that your
um committee will have some questions
for you
um so at this point um uh
i want to thank samantha for uh
interesting talk
and um we'll um dismiss some
everyone we'll ask the committee to stay
um and um we'll ask her any further
questions
so thank you thank you
[Music]